one of the biggest questions about
Avengers endgame has finally been
answered by none other than the
directors the Russo brothers themselves
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
this is a question that has been asked
so many times throughout the fandom
why didn't Hulk's arm in Avengers
in-game heal and recover after the snap
all throughout the history of the comics
and the MCU the Hulk is able to heal
granted we haven't seen much healing
from the Hulk in the MCU but in the
first Avengers film Bruce Banner does
mention that he put a bullet in his
brain and the Hulk spit it out the cell
was just in case you needed to kill me
but you can't I know I tried I got low
and then seemed in so I put a bullet in
my mouth and the other guys spit it out
so he was able to heal enough that a
bullet through the mouth to the brain
didn't kill him and in the comics he
always heals so what made the Russo
brothers decide not to have the hoax arm
heal after he performed snap and
Avengers in game well luckily for us
enough fans have asked the question and
they have finally come out and given us
an answer so I'll break down what they
said in this video but first if you'd
like a chance to win an Xbox one or a
ps4 be sure to subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your favorite superhero or villain so
you can enter my giveaway I'm picking a
winner when I hit 500,000 subscribers so
the question asked - why the Hulk's arm
didn't heal in Avengers in game after he
performed the snap was answered by the
Russo brothers in a Twitter Q&A with
wired again it's one of the most common
asked questions about a vendor's in game
and their answer may not be satisfying
for some people out there the Hulk has
taken on grenades he's taken on nuclear
bombs he's taken on pretty much
everything and has always healed and
when asked why he didn't heal in
Avengers and game the Russo brothers
replied with the Hulk has never come up
against every infinity stone in a
gauntlet and the pure power of the
stones Thanos is nearly invincible and
he did not heal either so clearly when
you wield the full power of the Infinity
stones its irreparable damage to your
beam so there you have it right from the
directors of Avengers and game
themselves the power of all of the
Infinity stones the full power of every
individual Infinity stone was simply too
much power
for the hulk's beam and in the comics
fan OHS has healing abilities as well
and we did not see him heal and Avengers
in game either
now this answer does make sense the
power of the Infinity stones are way
different than a nuclear bomb or
grenades or some type of explosion the
power stone by itself was used by the
celestial gods to destroy planets so not
only did the Hulk take on the power of
the power stone but he took on the power
of all six Infinity stones combined and
this was simply too much power for the
Hulk to take now the Hulk didn't die he
was strong enough to perform the snap
and survive and he's probably one of the
very few beans that could pull that off
so he was strong enough to snap but the
full power of all the Infinity stones
combined was just too much damage to his
arm which is why he wasn't able to heal
so this is the official answer to the
question of why didn't the Hulk's arm
heal after he performed the snap when
the Hulk always heals and it was
answered by the directors of Avengers in
game themselves so let me know is this
question satisfying to you be sure to
let me know in the comments down below
and also again don't forget to comment
with your favorite superhero or villain
like this video and subscribe to my
channel so you can enter my giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU don't forget to follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof